- Go long!
WAIT, STOP!
- Don’t limit my route, Kirk! I mean, Josh!
- We must never go there.
That’s the New York section of Gridiron Heights.
[Horn, honking]
- WOO! I ESCAPED!
A YEAR-AND-A-HALF! MY MOST PATIENT RUN YET!
Alright, I guess I'll go win a Super Bowl then.
- Let’s get the ball back. We need to prove we can get a big win!
- Here?
- Free comedy. Free comedy. Come just watch the Jets be the Jets.
- Hot dogs, I gotta get rid of these glory hogs. They have no place on a real team, OK?
- Hey, I'm blockin' here!
- Uncle Frank!
- Back when I started, Times Square still had that big Toys R Us.
- Hey, don’t you owe me something?
- Yes, Judge. One. Two.
- LOOK! I’M LIKE VRABEL IF HE FOLLOWED THE SAFETY GUIDELINES!
- JUDGE, I’VE GOT MY BUG EYES ON YOU.
THIS IS JETS TERRITORY.
- [Together:] AHHHHHHHH!
- We can bust out of this godforsaken town
Together we could net a third-round pick!
- OH, SORRY YOUSE ALL.
- Get out now while you can still…backup for an aging vet.
- DAMN YOU, NYC!
- Technically, we play in Jersey.
- Thank goodness we’re home safe.
- Uh Oh.
- [Together:] OW, OW, OW, OW.
- I'm just so happy.